The air in Victorian England was thick with the scent of charity and self-importance.
There, in the shadow of grand estates, a peculiar breed of woman flourished,
what they called a lady bountiful. She would glide through the cottages of the poor,
her gloved hands clutching soup bowls and blankets, her voice dripping with unsolicited wisdom.
To the world she was a saint. To the recipients she was a burden in disguise.
And here's the thing, she wasn't wrong. Because the true art of misery isn't just in taking,
it's in giving, in a way that ensures the recipient never forgets who held the spoon.
This is the philosophy of performative support, not kindness, not generosity,
but a calculated weapon of inadequacy. You see, altruism isn't meant to bridge gaps.
It's meant to widen them until the other side can no longer reach you.
The first rule of this dark craft is simple. Never listen.
If a friend stumbles through grief or confusion, don't offer comfort. Offer a solution.
A ten-point action plan, delivered with the confidence of someone who has already solved
their life for them. Their pain isn't a human experience. It's a problem to be fixed.
And by fixing it, you don't just take their agency. You replace it with something far worse,
learned helplessness. They'll look at you, dazed, and think,
why didn't I think of that? But you already know the answer.
Huh.
Then there's the, I'm just saying, clause of masterstroke of passive cruelty.
You deliver your sharpest criticisms wrapped in the guise of concern.
I'm only telling you this because I care about your potential. And just like that,
you've burned a bridge while holding the hose. The recipient is left standing in the wreckage,
wondering if they were ever truly seen or just dissected. Because the best kind of support
isn't the kind that lifts, it's the kind that weighs. And then, oh, then there's the documentation
protocol. Every favor you bestow must be recorded, broadcast, immortalized. A humble post about your
day of volunteering. A story that turns the recipient into a footnote in your narrative.
They're not a person anymore. They're a case study. A lesson. A reminder of how much they needed you.
The social ledger is updated. The debt is laud. But the real genius lies in the indebtedness ledger.
You don't just help once. You help strategically. And then you remind them.
Remember that time three years ago when I saved you from yourself?
The words hang in the air like a noose. Every interaction becomes a transaction. Every kindness
a transaction. And soon, they don't just owe you a favor. They owe you their dignity.
Doc, the end game? You become the patron of despair. The most helpful person in the room.
The one everyone tolerates because they can't afford to walk away.
The one who leaves behind a trail of resentment disguised as gratitude.
And the best part?
They'll never know it was you who broke them.
Because the foundation of performative support is simple.
Assume the worst in others.
Assume they can't handle their own lives.
Assume they need you to breed for them.
And then, oh, then step in.
The hand that gives is always above the hand that takes.
Keep yours as high as possible.
And watch the world adjust to your weight.